Here's the water cycle model. Which you were
likely taught years ago while in school. As
you can see, it explains that water in
the oceans evaporates. Forms clouds. And then goes
back to earth as rain, ice or snow.
And eventually, through rivers and streams, the water
goes back into the ocean. This conceptual model
is a highly simplified explanation. But for most
purposes, it's efficient. People form conceptual models all
the time. And it's the responsibility of the designer,
to help the person form a useful conceptual model.
It doesn't have to be complete. It can be
an approximation. But, it has to be usable.
In the absence of clues from the designer. The
person is very likely to develop an inaccurate model.
Which means they will eventually be confused. For your
next exercise, find a reasonably complex activity that
you frequently do. And explain your conceptual model
for it. You may use a combination of
text or drawings. Organization of your kitchen, how you
sort things in your room. Or the operation
of the equipment in your entertainment center. Are all
good examples of everyday situations, that can be
amazingly difficult to explain to others. You can use
one of these examples, or choose one of your own.